hello and welcome to the video playing
match p from the UK i guess yeah I try
this the set up again I think my results
are pretty good with that playing this
kind of very very natural set up I had
this quite often that I got it through
problems with night to d5 I should
probably like Queen g7 queen bee three
and then they played 95 okay I think
there's the same thing again Vigo bishop
HP does 95 so I try to protect his seven
ham
ok
so let's try to trade this yeah he
doesn't want to does not want to trade
hmm yo understandable um can I do
something with my pieces on the King
side or is that entirely naive by Queen
G for cribbage five or something and
something this is not a totally logical
idea maybe it just just too clumsy but
ok I'll try it I mean whites whites
position he has lots of stuff on the
green side this ship won't be too and so
on so I think there's some justification
to try to attack and quite often people
playing those kind of openings they have
issues with director texts I don't like
to be attacked in the early going Queen
d2 was possibly mysterious to me
t-to was a good square for the night
yeah not quite sure what why should do
my bishop 187 it looks funny but ok just
goes back ok hmm so Bishop g4 he will
play night to d2 is and I night you for
it's not not doing anything so maybe
bring bring another piece 97 to f5 or
something like that Oh
he doesn't seem to be concerned here at
all
okay interesting
hmm interesting knight on e4 i can i can
do night ever na na jie or now there are
sacrifices only three just around the
corner here whoa okay I know it closes
the bishop but gives me also some nice
central ideas you see play 44 here maybe
c64 anyway I have to do that
wow that sets it's a sharp move buddy
Wow d for poor okay head d takes and I
Texas a huge hole on these six okay so
I'll take him Knight takes wow I can
Bishop something I can wish up something
that's school English and Bishop g2 is
not working okay I'll get this also into
the game first
it looks very dangerous would like for
him to ask me
I've no idea what white is doing now
I yes also I mean he has some some
pieces around the Kings not like is
immediately checkmated yet it's pretty
clear maybe this was a bit much now in
d6 but i wanted to play quickly and I
shall never lower d6 ok it doesn't
doesn't actually do it not right away I
just have to fire head hope hope for the
best ona promotes right so then it
doesn't work unfortunately
time warner's way is he going there this
is actually made so i can take one we
have to check ok g2 is not working even
though it's all very very close
we're come on age to give me h to
checkmate I don't think you can prevent
it
white resign yeah it was just a ride bro
riot abroad here at the end I think I'm
spoiled a winning position somehow by
our good position somewhere around here
this is I think it should be it should
be dangerous for white at least a
computer gives equal but I thought I
thought later should be winning him this
is probably a bad idea d 6 is just
winning now which you didn't play
surprisingly this and I thought here
should be winning what maybe maybe this
is just so wild yam that you cannot
really assess it rook takes so currently
i'm look up right I'm gonna look up
computer says this is totally winning
for white zone it's got three connected
passes or something like that okay and
it seems I have no no mating attack okay
so it did this and against winning for
what okay or not now we have this hmm I
mean the computer will give a definite
answer but it's not clear that it gives
the answer of a couple of seconds now it
gives Queen f5 equal I have no idea okay
i just had to fire f5 and yeah okay it's
just losing but this it's losing for me
pawns are too dangerous for its still
winning for wine 23 now is the end of
the game and this is the end of the game
for him so yeah i probably maybe what's
i was a bit too
also anything thinking we might be known
time awesome that to overlook this mmm
yeah well he played some some strange
moves here maybe Queen d2 other was a
mouse slip or something like that what
is this back-and-forth thing I was
surprised that this is good full black
really with all the pieces near the king
but he get esse formal this is the key
thing it is deformed that default it was
a strong move probably otherwise
otherwise I'm taking command then the
center and this is busting it open at
the moment where I'm not perfectly
coordinated I think the engine gives
equal here with with with right with
correct play and I just I just played
this in a far too optimistic fresh on d6
not would have killed me Jim that was a
very tough very tough game ok thanks for
watching